welcome back to las vegas now the
following segment is sponsored by the
jazzy wellness and
loose skin is a problem for many of us
but we now have a non-invasive solution
here's tanya from the jazzy wellness
tell us more welcome back so tell us
what is an ultrasound skin lift
so um with our ultrasound skin
tightening it's basically an ultrasound
that penetrates to the muscle
it helps with the wrinkles fine lines
and tightening and firming the skin
so you say it penetrates the muscles how
how does it actually work then what's
the process how does it work
it helps basically with the collagen
levels on the production of collagen
it gives you that natural lifting and
tightening um it can last anywhere from
like three to five years
wow after how many treatments do you
start seeing the results
it's a one-time treatment um over the
next few weeks you'll start to feel the
immediate tightness
and then um over the next two to three
months you'll start to notice gradual
results
we're looking at some before and after
photos here of the neckline here what
areas do you guys treat
um we can do the full face on the neck
the chin
and even on the lower chest area these
before and after photos now we're
looking at an
arm here the neck it looks 20 30 years
younger how long
does the treatment take for let's say
for the neck how long you in there for
for that treatment
um anywhere from like 45 minutes to an
hour
now someone's watching right now and
they have some questions about whether
they want to get their neckline done
or their eyes done do you guys offer a
consultation
we do we offer free consultations and
then how would this come i mean it's not
invasive which is fantastic how does it
compare to other procedures that are out
there
well this one lasts you a bit longer
it's an alternative for those who are
not ready to get
surgery so um it's a start to help lift
and tighten the skin
and i think i mean seriously i think
everyone has some kind of issue with
with loose skin i mean we all do and
those results are fantastic
tanya you always have a special i'll run
down this special thank you so much for
joining us today we appreciate it
now for jazzy wellness so located at 900
south valley view suite 100 find them
online at
thejazzywellness.com and take advantage
of this special deal
the first 10 callers receive 40 percent
off
non-surgical facelift and las vegas now
we'll be right back